when the Empire Strikes Back first hits
cinemas in 1980 audiences didn't yet
know that Luke and Leia were twins or
that Darth Vader was their father
so when Leia kissed Luke early in the
movie in an effort to make Han Solo
jealous it was played as a joke that
introduced some mild romantic tension
between the three main characters and
upped the will they won't they stakes of
layer and Hans relationship it was only
three years later in Return of the Jedi
that Luke and Leia learnt that they were
actually siblings making that kiss
appeared a little more incestuous in
hindsight Yoda spoke of another the
other is spoken as your twin sister but
if you still cringe thinking about that
kiss just know that it could have been
so much worse thanks to a deleted scene
that was released on Disney Plus in
November 2019 we now know that the
relationship between Luke and Leia
almost got even more inappropriate in
the version of the same we all know han
and chewbacca come to the medical Bay to
say goodbye to Luke who's recovering
from his near-death experience with the
wampa Luke looks uncomfortable when Han
insists that Leia has feelings for him
and Leia comes back with an iconic
insult finally lay up brusque Lee kisses
Luke in front of Han then exits
triumphantly but in the deleted scene
it's made clear that Luke wasn't just
uncomfortable because he felt like a
third wheel in that version we learned
that he was actually jealous of Leia and
Hans obvious romantic tension after his
near-death experience awakens Luke - his
romantic feelings for Leia I'm thinking
you know
I might never get the chance Luke tries
to explain how he feels but when he goes
in for a kiss the ever reliable c-3po
interrupts the moment gone Luke tells
Leia that he plans to leave she accuses
him of deserting her and the resistance
just like Han who then arrives with
Chewbacca and the original scene plays
out yes the kiss is already bad once you
know that Luke and Leia are siblings but
this longer version introduces a love
triangle subplot that would have created
a totally different dynamic in the
movies Luke secretly being infatuated
with Leia would have thrown a major
wedge between the three main characters
and potentially stalled his Jedi
training since Jedi frown on trivial
matters like love interestingly creator
George Lucas has remained quiet on
whether or not he knew that Luke and
Leia were siblings during the making of
Empire if he already had that plot twist
figured out it would explain why he
decided that this would be romance had
to go
however Lucas has deftly avoided the
subject of this particular Lost
storyline he does like to hint that he
knew how the Star Wars saga would play
out all along that would mean he's fine
having sibling smooch when they didn't
know they're related but not with one
declaring a full-on crush on the other
however there is some evidence that Luke
and Leia weren't yet identified as
siblings by this point in the franchise
the fact that they got as far as filming
the deleted version of the medical bay
scene suggests that there was some
question about what kind of relationship
the two characters were going to have
plus in earlier drops of the Empire
script Vader was going to play on Luke's
romantic feelings for layer to turn him
to the dark side Luke was still supposed
to have a sister in these earlier drafts
although she was meant to be a totally
new character who wasn't going to appear
until Return of the Jedi but the theory
goes that this extra character proved to
be just too much for a story already
teeming with subplots instead after Leia
confessed her love for Han at the end of
M
Lucas decided to kill two stormtroopers
with one blaster shot and just have Leia
be Luke's sister making Star Wars easier
for everyone check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more loot
for videos about Star Wars are coming
out soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]